Is Harvard University
really holding its president?
Claudine Gay Doctor
Claudine Gay to the same standards
when it comes to the plagiarism
that it would
assail for students
committing the same offense.
You might recall Dr.
Gay, along with the president of MIT
and Penn, giving
generally seen as disastrous testimony
on Capitol Hill earlier
this month,
they failed to
explicitly say that calling
for the genocide of Jews on campus
would violate their campuses
codes of conduct
that, as well as gays commitment
to progressive policies
have made her many right
wing enemies who have
recently raised issues
about her scholarship.
But regardless of the provenance
of these allegations,
there is also the matter
of whether or not they're true.
Harvard's top governing
body said a review
revealed, quote,
Inadequate citations by Dr.
Gay in a few instances, but quote,
No violation of Harvard standards
for research misconduct, unquote.
The Harvard
Guide on Sourcing
says this on plagiarism, quote,
In academic writing,
it is considered
plagiarism to draw
any idea or any language
from someone else
without adequately crediting
that source in your paper, unquote.
Critics of Dr.
Gay and Harvard's
review of the allegations say that
there is a double standard going on here.
CNN's Matt Egan is following this.
Matt, what exactly is
Doctor Gay accused of here.
Which including Gay's career,
is under a microscope
and now she's facing
facing accusations of plagiarism.
Now, Gay recently
submitted corrections to two papers
she wrote as a professional academic
in 2001 and 2017.
However, there are clear
examples of plagiarism
that occurred in the 1990s
when Gay was studying for her Ph.D.
at Harvard.
And when one example,
Gay's 1997
dissertation lifted one paragraph
almost verbatim
from another,
from another source without citation.
That offense
appears to go against Harvard's
current guide on plagiarism,
which you stated earlier, Jake.
Harvard's Plager is and policy
says that students
who submit work without clear attribution
to sources will be, quote,
subject to disciplinary action
up to and including requirement
to withdraw from the college.
Now, the first publicly identified
instance of plagiarism
by gay comes from a failure
to properly cite sources in a 1993 essay.
These instances of plagiarism
were first reported
by the Washington Free Beacon.
CNN's analysis, led by my colleague
and Stack, confirmed
some of the main allegations
in that reporting.
Now, Harvard's top governing
body said in a statement last week
it became aware of plagiarism allegations
against gay in late October.
An independent review
found a few instances
of missing citations,
but no violation of Harvard standards.
However, it's not clear
whether that review included
Gay's 1997 dissertation.
Now, neither Harvard nor Gay
have commented
on the allegations
of plagiarism from the 1990s.
CNN reached out to Harvard
with a list of questions,
but the school declined to comment.
In a previous statement, Gay said, quote,
I stand by the integrity
of my scholarship.
Throughout my career,
I have worked to ensure
my scholarship adheres
to the highest academic standards.
Now, we should note that the plagiarism
allegations against Gay
were first circulated
by conservative activist activists.
One of those activists
has also criticized gay
and Harvard's diversity policies
and Gay's most outspoken critic.
Hedge fund
billionaire Bill
Ackman has also highlighted
the plagiarism charges,
and he's argued without evidence
that Harvard
only hired gay
to fulfill diversity requirements.
Now, plagiarism
experts that CNN spoke to stressed
that this is a very complex issue.
These experts were divided on
whether Gay's omissions warrant
any punishment,
but none of them called
for her to be fired.
And they noted it's
quite rare for academics
to be fired for plagiarism.
Jake,
what else are critics and plagiarism
experts saying about Harvard's
review of these plagiarism allegations?
Well, one
criticism is the lightning fast
speed that Harvard pulled off
this independent review.
These types of plagiarism reviews,
they can take anywhere from six months
to two years.
This one, not even two months.
Another criticism
is that there's a double standard,
one set of rules for the students.
Another for the president
of the university.
I do think we should emphasize,
though, that the defense
that these flames have been fired
and fueled by activists,
not activists,
who are really concerned
about academic citation methods,
but right wing activists
who are trying to push out
the presidents of Ivy League schools
who they feel are too liberal.
One last point here, Jake.
Remember, when you talk about plagiarism,
it really falls
into two different categories.
One is copying without attribution.
There's also the more serious allegation
of stealing someone else's ideas.
And in this instance,
these allegations of plagiarism
are really all in the former camp.
So, yes,
sloppy citations, but no, not idea.
Theft. Yes.
The big question, I think, in
the future
is how will Harvard be able to punish
any students
found guilty of the
same offense without
inviting a lawsuit?
Because if she gets away with something
that students can't get away with,
that could be messy
legally for the school,
which I'm sure Harvard's lawyers
have thought about way before.
I just said that.
Madigan, Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.